et pour revenir sur ces oppositions au
pass sanitaires on va retrouver jean
paul stahl il est infectiologues au chu
de grenoble grenoble alpes et olivier
marais et au patron du café marzotto à
paris
messieurs bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce soir sur arte france
pour commencer cette grogne des français
cet après midi cette grotte donc le pass
sanitaires on n'a pas encore les
chiffres officiels de la participation
mais à l'oeil sur place on voit qu'il y
avait tout de même du monde jean paul
stahl vous qui êtes infectiologues
est-ce que vous la comprenez cette
opposition au pass sanitaire juger on
l'entendait liberticide par ses
participants
absolument pas je ne comprends
absolument pas au contraire c'est une
restriction de ma liberté que de que de
que de refuser le pass and i ter donc
liberté contre liberté où vous voyez
bien qu'on âge dans l'ubuesque
de toute façon c'est extrêmement simple
le virus y circulent d'un individu
porteur un individu récepteur
si on ne fait pas la passe et iter mais
on fait un confinement et instruments là
toute la population sera sera impactée
par ce que quelques-uns se refuse à sept
minimes contracte donc là franchement
c'est quelque chose que je n'arrive pas
à comprendre mais d'un autre côté il
faut aussi relativiser des choses il ya
moins de manifestants que deux personnes
que le moins de manifestants chaque
samedi que deux personnes qui se font
vacciner tous les jours
donc là encore il faut pas faut pas non
plus exagérer et donner une importance
qu'ils n'ont pas assez opposition alors
l'idée pareto vous vous êtes un patron
de café à paris
quand finalement vous vous entendez un
que le pass à lithaire c'est un moindre
mal et de toute façon on n'a pas le
choix il le faut pour éviter la
propagation du virus qu'est ce que vous
répondez
moi je suis pas je suis pas
infectiologues c'est pas moi qui suis
maître de la politique ce que je vois
par contre c'est que nous on nous
utilise comme comme
une espèce de péage et que nous
concernant ce tout n'est pas tout n'est
pas très clair voilà j'ai encore le cas
aujourd'hui j'ai des gens des touristes
qui seront vaccinés y en a qui arrivent
avec son face
maver qui était
[Musique]
grec
un autre cas vdc vaccin donc ils n'ont
pas de qr code on se retrouve confronté
à plein de situations comme ça sur le
sur le sur le système c'est pareil les
gens qui ont comme hulk au vide depuis
moins de six mois et cetera ils ont pas
accès aux qr codes nous on a pas moyen
de vérifier donc on se retrouve un petit
peu pris entre le marteau et l'enclume
parce qu'on risque de grosses en ce jour
aux sanctions voilà donc après sur paris
on a un petit peu moins quand même le
problème parce que je crois que sur
paris on a un taux de vaccination qui
est très épais
mais mais mais c'est nous qui portons le
risque de la sanction et qui portons
aussi le la vérification donc sauf que
la situation était quelque peu injuste
et ça nous impacte quand même sur le
business parce que tous les jours
vérifier en permanence en permanence en
permanence les passes sanitaires on a
des contrôles de police des contrôles de
police par exemple qui viennent il
demandait que ce n'est pas ça ni taire à
tout le monde 1 voilà
et on a aussi des contrôles de police
qui sont faits avec des gens qu'ils
s'assoient en terrasse 1 et piquant les
contrôles qu'on leur demande leur pas ce
cas il nous montre la carte de police en
nous disant
non c'était juste pour voir si vous
deviez des vérifications mais on n'est
pas dans l'histoire nous n'est pas les
méchants
c'est pas d'ailleurs si un camp des
gentils et des méchants chacun porte la
responsabilité de ses choix 1 mais on
est un petit peu sur exposé en risque
et on n'en tire aucun bénéfice voilà on
entend les difficultés de d'olivier
barreto dans son quotidien dans sa
profession alors on le sait on a comme
armes aujourd'hui la vaccination on sait
aussi avec certitude que être vaccinés
finalement n'empêche pas de contaminer
est-ce que se donne cette donnée avec
cette donnée est ce qu'on il faudrait
pas repenser le principe du pass
sanitaire selon roues
qui sont on peut pas faire mieux déjà
être vaccinés c'est l'assurance de ne
pas faire de forme grave pour vous qui
êtes vacciné et deuxièmement c'est aussi
l'assurance de ne pas transmettre de
façon importante à lens est vrai qu'il y
à des personnes vaccinées qu'ils peuvent
être des transmetteurs mais la
proportion mais n'est pas très
importante donc globalement on réduit la
circulation du virus quoi qu'il arrive
et encore une fois tous ceux qui sont
contre quelles solutions ils veulent je
rappelle qu'on parle là de quelque chose
comme 120 mille morts
jusque là je n'entends pas de quelques
broutilles justement olivier marzotto on
vous voyait sourire quand
jean paul stahl vous allez on peut pas
faire mieux est-ce que vous avez
d'autres solutions est ce qu'on peut
faire mieux selon vous non pas moi en
tout cas je pense qu'il ya des gens qui
sont payés à l'année pour réfléchir aux
gouvernements aux solutions le problème
et nous ce qu'on retour ce qu'on a
souvent des gens puisque on est un petit
peu aussi une interface
on a expliqué aux gens que un moment
finalement être en extérieur
ça ne risque est quasiment rien
aujourd'hui on est on est on a une belle
arrière saison tous les gens sont en
terrasse donc qu'ils comprennent pas
trop pourquoi tout d'un coup il faut
être absolument absolument vacciner
encore une fois je le répète je crois
qu'on a un taux de vaccination qui est
relativement élevé à paris donc on n'est
pas autres confrontés à ce problème à 1
mais on a aussi nous la question qui se
pose c'est si effectivement tout le
monde être vaccinés pourquoi et là je
parle en tant que professionnel c'est la
chair pourquoi nous faire porter à nous
le risque pourquoi pas imposer une
vaccination obligatoire pour tout le
monde voilà et pourquoi pas aller
jusqu'au bout de la démarche plutôt que
exposé des gens qui n'ont pas leurs
passes avec une amende et puis exposé et
surtout des gens qui sont juste là pour
faire du commerce à des missions de
contrôle et derrière à des risques de
sanctions qui peuvent mettre en péril la
vie de leur entreprise voilà moi c'est
vraiment la question que je me pose
aller jusqu'au bout de la jetée au
gouvernement les jusqu'au bout de la
démarche imposée la vaccination ne
m'étais pas des professions en
porte-à-faux vis-à-vis de leurs clients
vis-à-vis des risques qu'ils font courir
à leurs entreprises et à leurs salariés
joe ball saleh est ce que au fond c'est
vrai que ça n'aurait pas été plus clair
d'imposer franchement la vaccination
pour pour tout le monde et de ne pas
faire porter certaines responsabilités à
des professionnels notamment de
restaurants et bars
alors oui le moi je suis partisan de la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous mais
ceci dit prêt il ya un problème pratique
c'est à dire que le circuit législatif
le conseil d'état et conseil
constitutionnel qui aurait été un manque
à bhl était tout à fait incompatible
avec l'urgence qu'il y avait à contrôler
l'épidémie c'est à dire qu'on aurait eu
un résultat quelque chose comme en
janvier ou en février c'était trop tard
ici avait pas eu ça on n'y avait pas eu
le passé s'il n'y avait pas eu la
vaccination de masse qui va avec et
d'une façon le passé temps une façon
d'arriver à la vaccination on serait en
ce moment dans une quatrième vague
absolument redoutable avec un variant
beaucoup plus contagieux et avec 1 re
confinement inéluctable j'étais bien que
la france serait fermée donc voila moi
ce que je vois c'est que il a fallu
faire avec ce qui était possible ce qui
était réaliste et puis et puis ma foi
débrouille avec ça et chacun est
responsable c'est à dire que les
propriétaires de restaurants de cafés de
deux magasins etc comme nous les
médecins comme tout le monde dans la rue
tout le monde est responsable il s'agit
pas de le dire le virus il est à droite
il est à gauche il est au mieux inutile
un gilet de telle ou telle couleur le
virus il s'en fiche de tout ça le virus
il se transmet d'un individu à l'autre
est la seule façon de raisonner c'est de
savoir à quel endroit il y a le plus de
risques qu'ils se transmettent pour
qu'il est lié à ces endroits là le plus
de réglementation possible pour éviter
cette transmission et il se trouve là
toutes les études dans le monde entier
mais y compris celles de l'institut
pasteur en france démontre que le
secteur de la restauration au sens très
large et était avant qu'ils soient
fermés dans les différents compare les
différents confinement et était un lieu
de haute transmission du virus alors il
reste il aurait ce qu'elle quelques
secondes olivier marzotto vous voulez
répondre pour conclure en quelques mots
ouais je trouve ça on pas nous on suit
les règles du jeu qu'on nous impose de
toute façon mais quand j'entends
monsieur parler d'études etc etc que
nous avec les syndicats on a demandé
sans cesse mise à part une vague étude
américaine qui s'est fait dans un fast
food sans aucun protocole sanitaire etc
etc il n'y a jamais eu d'études
sérieuses au fait en france sur sur les
chr ou alors fort et nous les donner
parce qu'on les a pas et deuxièmement et
dans l'institut pasteur en france oui à
l'écouter on les a on les a pas eues sur
le caractère récent de les communiquer
alors je pense mais en tout cas on est
les i pour conclure on arrive au terme
de ce débat messieurs ouais de toute
façon je pense que la grande grande
grande majorité de la profession ça sert
jouent chez eux a de toute façon tu es
pour nous c'est pas une question
d'opinion odette pour ou d'être contre a
de toute façon c'est une question de
continuer à faire vivre nos actifs notre
activité de continuer à faire la donner
un semblant de vie à l'ensemble de la
population voilà et on n'a pas le choix
mais on aimerait ne pas être
être si on me dit oh tu au mieux tu veux
en permanence merci en tout cas tous les
deux d'avoir des battus ce soir sur rtl
france merci à vous jean paul stahl
infectiologues au chu de grenoble alpes
merci à vous olivier var et aux lettres
patron de café marzo à paris